have you ever tried to reheat fast food
i find myself always chasing that level
of deliciousness that
like right when you get it it's so good
every single time
fast food fries are just one of those
foods that is just
superior to most things so for this
video i'm going to be testing all the
ways i can think of to reheat fast food
to get as close as i can to being
as good as possible we're gonna focus on
two staples burger and fries we gotta
put all these burgers in the fridge
i almost forgot about our sack of fries
through the magic of editing we are
ready to start
i don't know why i did that this is
going to give us a good sense of where
our starting line for each test is going
to be
the fact that i can grip the top bun and
everything just kind of stays like i
really think
[Music]
cold fries not good cross-section here
without question the simplest reheating
technique
we're talking microwave over here
i'm gonna start with a minute and then
just kind of eyeball it from there
sitting
on the floor in front of the microwave
even though it's only been 20 seconds i
am smelling a lot of uh let's go
10 more seconds all right that's enough
the bun is very hot the fries are very
hot but i
don't like what i'm feeling it's been
less than a minute it smells like fast
food
i can feel the heat like radiating off
of this
microwave come on it's the the right
temperature of what you want
a french fry to be but it is so limp
i expected that and i don't know if
there's a way to really get around that
from a microwave but
the burger i have a little more faith in
honestly it's so hot
[Music]
shocking electrifying the bun has lost a
lot
it's basically the same texture as the
burger that's what are we gonna do i am
sweating so bad there's a lot of things
going right
for microwave that took literally no
time at all and the burger patty is
pretty ideal the microwave burger
gets i gotta go seven i'm thinking what
the end of this video should be
is borrowing the perfect cooking
technique for each ingredient
to then construct the ultimate reheat
method we're gonna go oven 350 sounds
like a pretty decent
starting point i think i'm gonna wrap
the whole thing in foil
and toss some fries on the side
i want to make sure they all have room
toss that in
it's been about five minutes sizzling a
little bit
give that a little flip around all right
it's been about 10 minutes i think it's
time to eat our oven test
immediate thoughts i'm liking the way
the fries look
the fries are serious if these were in
the oven for any longer
they would have started drying out they
have a good crisp
the cheese is melty again the bun is a
little crispy on the outside
let's talk about it it's cooked more
evenly
throughout than i thought it would be
taking into consideration the burger and
fries together
out of 10 like a seven and a half it's
really strong
time to bust out some pans
i think for our pan method this is
definitely gonna be a deconstruction
don't break my plan was to put the
burger patty
in the skillet and also have the buns
kind of heat up next to it separately i
think we just gotta see what happens i'm
gonna put
the buns in cold soften up a little bit
i'll take them out before adding the
patty and then i'll put our fries
in our second skillet how cocky will he
get with the fries
this bun i'm confident that i can flip
over and kind of toast on both sides
test they're not cold anymore could be
crisper i don't want to forget about
these buns i think i'm gonna pull that
off let's go burger in i forgot that the
cheese and condiments and pickles are
all going to be stuck to it the fries
have been going for about five minutes
so i think we're going to turn that off
from about medium heat i want you guys
to hear this
go ahead and put this on our is there
cheese on the bottom too
newly assembled pan burger
while it may be more annoying to
constantly shake a pan around full of
fries
those are better than the oven
everything still
feels warm and hot hmm
that is quite nice the bun is still
light and fluffy
it's not dried out like it was in the
oven it's heated all the way through
because we separated everything
i gotta go like eight and a half i know
that's a
big jump from our oven score i have
little to no idea how this next method
is gonna go air fryer
plug she awakens let's go
350. nice and hot
little batty in here keep an eye on you
cries in everybody's situated
i'm thinking around probably five
minutes then we're gonna take another
peek
maybe flip maybe toss a couple guys
around in five
minutes
oh no
[Music]
i didn't think five minutes would be a
long time in the air fryer however
the fries look good let's give the fries
a shot first
a little dry oh boy a little crunchy
realistically most of the bun is pretty
dried out the burger is still heated
through really nicely which i didn't
expect
for the airfryer fries and
burger seven now i think the most
important part comes into play what
pieces do i use to construct
the ultimate reheated fast food burger
and fries we are going to put
the fries in the pan we are preheating
the oven so that we can put the burger
bun
in the oven and as for the patty itself
wild card we're gonna go
full microwave on the burger patty
[Music]
delightful now
[Applause]
huh gotta take a lap this is how you
reheat a fast food burger and fries it
may sound like a lot was happening but
in reality
this all took place in under five
minutes with really common household
items
absolutely worth the effort thank you
for watching
let me know in the comments what other
common fast food items you want me to
test in terms of reheating techniques
and then we'll try and frankenstein
our own perfect method bye bye